bonsoir mon excimer bonsoir c'est
physique alors lis pas les jim lee
cinéma il ya deux semaines qui ont
relancé leurs activités mais toujours
rien pour les salles de spectacle est ce
que vous vous expliquer que les salles
de spectacle ne soit pas encore ouverte
j'ai écouté j'ai confiance qui vont
avoir une décision cohérente qui va nous
est annoncée bientôt et que on parle du
26 mars il a entre autres pour des
installations en zone rouge que la même
chose doit s'appliquer pour les salles
de spectacle ont déjà en zone orange
c'est déjà possible
alors ce qu'on a rappelé dans notre
lettre je vous rappeler que c'est le
quartier des spectacles le quartier des
spectacles
c'est le plus grand quartier de
divertissement en afrique en amérique du
nord c'est énorme c'est une trentaine de
salles intérieures
c'est des espaces extérieurs les
festivals donc on voulait rappeler
combien c'est important la culture
combien c'est important on parle
beaucoup de santé mentale on a beaucoup
justifier la reprise d'activité physique
sportive pour la santé mentale des
jeunes en particulier
mais la culture c'est aussi un boom
c'est aussi quelque chose qui nous
nourrit et vous ayez donné l'importance
économique
c'est ça vous avez cette semaine nous ne
sommes pas juste de la culture mais de
l'économie également
et quand vous dites une réouverture
cohérente là ça veut dire quoi ça mais
c'est à dire une décision cohérente
c'est à dire si on a on décide d'ouvrir
tous les dieux que donc que vous avez
mentionné dans votre introduction
normalement on devrait permettre aux
salles de spectacles d'ouvrir avec
évidemment un certain nombre de
consignes j'arrive du cinéma justement
les salles de cinéma sont ouvertes
depuis les jours maintenant j'en arrive
c'est impeccable suffit lyon on arrive
on nous demande de changer de masque
il ya des choses pour se désinfecter les
mains lui un nombre de places qui sont
assignés peut-être dans une salle de 250
places être quarantaine de places qui
sont possibles mais toutes les règles
sont pas sont bien appliquées pour que
ce soit sécuritaire dont les pubs l'on
peut faire une chose dans une amende
ha absolument vous savez on a eu
quelques réouverture qui ont été
permises à la fin de l'été dernier et lé
au début de l'automne est là au lieu
aucun cas de contamination qui a été
associé aux salles de spectacle
évidemment
et là c'est important de mentionner
quand on dit aux joueurs on veut ouvrir
on le sait ont fait des sondages
régulièrement le public veut revenir en
salles le public peut aussi être certain
que les lieux sont sécuritaires
il ya des programmes de soutien et on
doit reconnaître qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
programmes de soutien depuis un an pour
les actions culturelles pour le milieu
culturel et si on peut permettre aux
salles de réouvrir cbi coups
d'opérations souvent vont être
équivalent à 100 % mais si on impose un
nombre limité de personnes il faudra
maintenir ses programmes de compensation
pour 5 ou havre se dire elles arriveront
pas parce que ces progrès c'est pas
viable à 25 ou à prendre 3 % de capacité
cpo viable et est ce que ça prend un
couvre-feu plus tard lé don à 21 h 30 au
lieu de 20h et est seul et les gens des
salles les opérateurs de salles de
cinéma l'ont dit il faudrait que ça soit
9h30 parce que les gens sont habitués
d'avoir des spectacles à cette heure des
représentations de cinéma à cette heure
là évidemment qu'elle couvre feu à huit
heures c'est impossible donc de
repousser le couvre-feu à 9h30 donc oui
il faut ouvrir les salles c'est
important ça fait partie de notre vie
c'est bon pour la santé mentale c'est
bon pour la collectivité maintenir une
modélisation des programmes de soutien
pour s'adapter aux différentes mesures
qui seront demandés aux sai le
couvre-feu donc reporté à 9h30
parce qu'il faut bien comprendre que nos
salles sont très différentes les unes
des autres
juste le quartier des spectacles vous
avez des foufounes électriques et vous
avez la salle où le foot pelletier vous
avez des théâtres complètement privé
comme le club soda
donc faut absolument s'ajuster aussi à
la réalité de chacun de ces salles d'un
est ambigu et en plus madame simard au
coeur de
des spectacles il y a les artistes et
les artistes depuis un an sont dans une
précarité son nom la plupart ne
travaille pas depuis un an les plus
meurtries ce sont les artistes ce sont
les interprètes ce sont les musiciens
les acteurs
alors oui il ya eu quand même des
captations de spectacles qui est quand
même un certain nombre de choses qui ont
été faites depuis un an mais vivement
qu'on puisse reprendre et que snow
artistes puissent travailler vous
l'avons dit gloire l'allongement de six
morts mais je pense que d'ici quelques
jours je josé je sais que notre lettre a
été bien accueilli et j'attends la
semaine prochaine ces annonces là je
pense qu'elles vont faire suite aux
annonces d'aujourd'hui faite par la
ministre charest pour d'espoir l'espoir
etc permettent normalement c'est dire
que j ai un devoir de cohérence là un
pour couvrir des sports pour couvrir des
gym et pas ouvrir une salle de spectacle
avec des conseils mais évidemment qui me
seront exigés par la santé publique je
pense que ça va c'est logique vu que non
mais d'ici quelques jours
il nous faut du temps un théâtre pour
monter une pièce pour reprogrammer
il faut quand même avoir un certain
préavis de quelques semaines c'est pas
tout le monde doit l'ouvrir aux coups de
suite mais c'est je pense que le message
a été compris que parfait madame simard
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
merci d'avoir évité pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
oh